listen there's this whole wave of
[ __ ] talking about not busting
nuts um
see my attention semen retention kevin
gates talk about it joey badass talk
about i heard you talk about it
please elaborate no it's good for you um
first and foremost
yo yo yo ejaculation your nut is is life
so once you give a part of life away
you lose a part of life you know
um i tell everybody this example with
oneness you can run eight miles it's
like the equivalent to eight miles you
know how many miles not many footsteps
that is really
wow one that can make a whole child you
think you can't
you can't you know i'm saying you can't
go the extra mile to do your work or do
extra stuff within that i'm saying so
it's better to keep it in and you'll
feel better like just go on the same
retention like you know how long
oh just try like
how do you have sex i mean often i'm
married my wife's beautiful we'd be
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying so like
let's just try i feel like my wife would
be offended if i didn't come though
she'd be like what the [ __ ] and i'd be
like no i ended up chopping
18 year old kid told me i i i'm too
retention
so um
okay so is it hard to like
not
get your [ __ ] off you gotta have a goal
if you put a goal in place if you be
like okay this week
i want to record seven songs
and this is like a song a day you know
if this show go attack it you know what
i'm saying but with you having sex and
busting the honey and that's it might
not be possible cause
let me make it more realistic i'ma speak
on my terms like i try to record three
songs a night if i'm if i'm in for a
week if i got a week recording session
i'm trying to do three songs
there's 21 songs in one week that's a
that's an album two albums so
now i'm saying if that's my focus if
that's my approach going into that week
i can't have six because i'm gonna be
too tired
it's certain hours that's gonna be
knocked off with just each night each
night a certain hour will be knocked off
so um once you develop a goal or focus
something to drive towards i feel like
that's when you implement it you know
so
when you are doing retention semen
retention and then you still [ __ ] right
i'm just trying to understand this i
haven't done it to where i'm [ __ ] and
then like so you'll just be celibate
yeah i'd just be settling oh okay okay
okay yeah i'm not [ __ ] in i'm like
i'm not sometimes i cuz i'm just
wondering if that's the case when do you
know when it's over no i ain't got the
you know like when you're like all right
you good because i'm i'm this okay okay
okay okay okay so you just have to
you'll tell wifey like hey look the next
week i'm chilling
i got an album to finish yeah something
like that i got uh a a marathon i'm
training for yes that's why boxers
aren't supposed to boxing no sports